welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and a new promo for Disney plus
revealed some very intriguing new shots
from Loki season 2 as well as some other
titles of Interest like Marvel secret
Invasion and the Mandalorian all mixed
in with about a dozen different angles
of Nicholas Holt on Hulu's the great
yeah that's what we're going to spend
money on this Disney Plus Hulu bundle
the great not the return of Disney
Plus's greatest series and since
literally every frame of Loki warrants
its own Deep dive I'm going to break
down all these new shots and the
surprising buttload of info we can gain
from them and Hell while I'm at it let's
look at these new shots of secret
Invasion too also subscribe to new
Rockstar's new channel the Deep dive
launching February 17th in which one of
my launch Day videos will be a deep dive
into the six episodes of Loki season one
and how we actually learn a lot about he
who remains relationship with the Kang
Dynasty if you re-watch that series
closely okay let's take a look at this
Disney Plus promo coming this year
everything to The Who and Disney plus
bundle this is why we're perfect
together hang on
you're a different Adventure this is
just the beginning
soon okay we gotta start with these new
shots from Loki season two we hear Tom
hiddleston's voice as Loki's saying this
is about everything and then two quick
shots of Loki that we saw in the past
Disney Plus promo a close-up of Loki in
its bright location and then another in
an orange room where he's either signing
or maybe having his thumb print scanned
on this orange device that looks like an
electronic game that they converted into
a prop but then this amazing shot that I
initially saw in the d23 trailer for
Loki season 2 Loki Jabs a TVA pruning
stick into a wall in the TBA depicting a
mural of the timekeepers and I can't
tell even the footage that I saw that
this will prune back that wall to reveal
a row of giant faces those of Jonathan
Majors as Kang or he remains now here
you can see in the foreground of the
shot a severed time keeper head the one
that Sylvie decapitated sitting his head
rolling down toward them creepily this
is also the one that had that dying
whisper
which of course were also he remains
final words after Sylvie stabbed him see
you soon but also look closely in the
far right of this shot that is someone
else's hand I'm gonna guess it's B15 as
she tries to stop Loki from defacing
this glorious art now this mural shows
the three time Keepers with the braided
sacred timeline stretched in front of
them in the TVA hourglass logo at the
center and that is where Loki strikes
also notice that Loki is wearing his
same outfit that he was wearing in the
final shot of Loki season 1 when he was
pushed back in the TVA through a Time
door opened by Sylvie so that she could
kill he remains back in the sidville at
the end of time so this is most likely
that same TVA just moments after that
scene took place so Loki must now be in
the process of trying to convince Mobius
in B15 who had been reset and
brainwashed didn't know who he was that
the timekeepers were just a smoke screen
and he remains is truly the man behind
the curtain but we gotta wonder why is
this timekeeper mural still up when at
the center of the TVA a looming statue
of Kang is already there my thinking is
that the Kang iconography was always
there but the TVA and Loki were
brainwashed or under a kind of spell or
temporal filter to see every image of
Kang that was there as the illusion of
the trio of timekeepers that could be
why the central timekeeper vaguely looks
like Jonathan Majors like imagine the
robots in HBO's Westworld whenever they
see a door or a person or something that
they should not see it literally appears
invisible to them their mind filters it
out and they just respond doesn't look
like anything to me and so only Loki now
sees that Central statue is actually
Kang because he has met he remains the
scales have fallen from his eyes he has
been unplugged and he sees through the
smoke screen and so he now has gone down
to that time keeper Lair he's grabbed a
separate head trying to convince
everyone Mobius and B15 have been reset
so they don't see anything wrong with
this until Loki's finally able to use
that pruning stick to unwind the
temporal filter that he remates had
installed in the TVA by the way the
ability to see through the filter could
apply to rinselayer who I'm pretty sure
did have a past romantic relation ship
with one of the Kang variants a witch
would make her haunted by her ex staring
down at her in her workplace every day
we know the whole TVA must operate on
some kind of filter we don't really see
any light source where Miss minutes is
projected from and Loki and Sylvie's
magic does not work in the TVA it's a
neutralized sorcerer magic there must be
some other kind of mechanism at work
running its own illusion protocol now
being hungry is a part of Being Human I
gotta eat every day but what I don't
gotta do is figure out what to eat or
how to cook it thanks to factor and yes
in other videos you'll hear me talk
about hellofresh but factor is now owned
by hellofresh I use both without them I
don't know I just eat chips I don't know
but Factor not only lets me skip the
trip to the grocery store but I also get
to skip chopping prepping and cleaning
up Factor meals are ready in two minutes
so all you have to do is heat and enjoy
Factor has 34 weekly options so I never
get tired of what I'm eating plus if you
want to switch things up or just you
know Pat out the snack selection in your
pantry bacter has an assortment of over
36 quick bites smoothies juices and more
satisfying add-ons each mail is prepared
by chefs and approved by dietitians so
you know you'll feel good about what
you're eating no matter what your diet
calls for Factor has keto calorie smart
vegan vegetarian and Protein Plus meals
on the menu each week this month I got
this poblano pepper beef bowl that was
just so easy to prep and it tasted so
good I can't illustrate to you how good
the smells oh it's gonna be hot
[Music]
oh it's like really well seasoned and
it's really good I also got like a black
pepper pork chop I can't wait to try
jalapeno cheddar chicken that I got a
second time because I really really
liked it last time the mushroom for
seedless some vegan chicken I just
really got a great mix so to get some
easy delicious meals of your own just
head to factor75.com or click the link
below and use the code rockstars50 to
get 50 off your first Factor box once
more that's factor75.com and use the
code rockstars50 to get 50 off your
first Factor box now there's another new
shot showing Loki back in his jacket
using a baton to deflect an attack or
maybe unleash a green spell of his own
Loki doesn't need a wand to release his
green sorcery so I'm guessing he's in a
kind of wizard duel with Sylvie it's
hard to tell what this room is but it
does look like some amazing production
design storage room or archive room and
if you look very closely behind Loki on
the lower right as he turns he is
shielding someone from this spell and
I'm pretty sure that's our guy kihui
Kwan Golden Globe winner recent Oscar
nominee for everything everywhere all at
once and 80s child star confirmed nd20 3
to play a role in season 2 as a TBA
archivist maybe a technology expert and
rumored to be named or a Boris and the
last shot we saved Loki in this trailer
is Loki wearing a 1970s tuxedo saying
spoton which you know from previous
trailers him with Mobius and a couple
other Loki variants or duplicates in a
London Alleyway now before Loki this
year on Disney plus will reportedly be
secret evasion rumored to be dropping in
May while Loki comes out later in the
summer there are a few shots from Secret
invasion in this promo we see a snarling
scroll with purple splotches on his face
Nick Fury with zypatch Emilia Clark's
character scene this is just the
beginning now we previously speculated
that Clark might be playing the squirrel
Queen varanki but a series of animated
gifs officially released by Marvel late
last year included a file name that
listed her characters Abigail brand
Abigail brand of course is the director
of Sword in the comics seen on the space
station the peak and based off of the
footage I saw in d23 that Peak space
station will appear in the Marvels this
summer there's also a little later in
this promo a new shot from Secret
Invasion showing James Rhodes War
Machine Rudy descending a staircase he
and his group all wear ID badges which
makes me think they are visiting the
White House which requires all visitors
to wear badges just like this Brody
could be on his way for a meeting with
president ritzen who in secret Invasion
will be played by German Mulroney with
the Super Bowl coming this Sunday
there's good chance we'll see Fuller
versions of these trailers and release
dates or when these are coming to Disney
plus I'm gonna be on the clock with
reactions and breakdowns here on new
rockstars and hey if you like this shirt
I'm wearing it is our quantumania
inspired Kanga conqueror shirt that you
can get at nerd riot.shop and of course
another reminder to subscribe to our new
channel the Deep dive our launch Day is
coming up at the end of next week
February 17th I'm so excited you can
follow me on Instagram and Twitter at
eavos follow me rockstars And subscribe
to new rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
foreign
[Music]